[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant le débat sur france 24 la
tension monte autour de la question de
l'ukraine washington a annoncé ce
week-end le rapatriement des familles de
diplomates et a détaillé et lourde
sanction que subirait la russie en cas
d'invasion de l'ukraine les pays de
l'otan ou envoyer des navires et des
avions de combat pour renforcer leur
défense en europe de l'est moscou et
minsk ont annoncé l'organisation
d'exercices impromptue en biélorussie
les etats-unis et les européens ont pris
des mesures pour protéger les
approvisionnements en gaz naturel de
l'europe si jamais la russie coupelles
robinet mails macron a rencontré le
chancelier allemand olaf scholz il
affiche une unité pour appeler à la
désescalade alors la guerre est-elle
inévitable
quels sont les intérêts de chaque
protagoniste jusqu'où peut aller la
lumière poutine la france et l'allemagne
ont elles une carte à jouer peut-on
aller vers une désescalade en discute
avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir
à mes côtés et pierre servant bonsoir
spécialiste des questions de défense
colonel de réserve hauteur de 50 nuance
de guerre aux éditions perrin également
avec nous julien theron bonsoir
enseignant à sciences po paris
spécialiste des conflits et des
relations internationales
auteur de poutine la stratégie du
désordre ses co écrit avec isabelle
mandraud et c'est le monde tallandier
nous avons avec nous également par skype
de berlats ingeborg grèce le bonsoir
députée allemande de là à céder ou le
parti conservateur allemand bienvenue à
vous et merci beaucoup et en duplex de
londres nous allons avec nous de nice
mcshane ancien ministre des affaires
européennes britannique bonsoir et
bienvenue également
bosworth à lui avant de démarrer ce
débat je vous pose tout de suite de
regarder la préparation des forces de
l'otan en cas d'agression au russe en
ukraine avec harold gérard
l'otan montre ses muscles un
renforcement annoncé des capacités
militaires en europe de l'est avec un
objectif dissuader la russie
d'intervenir en ukraine
nous projettons de renforcer notre
présence en europe de l'est et cela pour
inclure le déploiement d'encore plus de
soldats de l'otan disent ces
déploiements sont proportionnée et
adaptée à nos engagements internationaux
il renforce la sécurité de l'europe pour
nous tous
l'otan compte environ 4000 soldats
déployés en pologne et dans les pays
baltes mais aussi des chars d'assaut des
défenses aériennes et des unités de
renseignement et de surveillance face à
la russie qui continue d'encercler
l'ukraine les membres de l'otan
accentuent la pression le danemark
envoie des avions de combat en lituanie
l'espagne envoie l4 avion et trois
navires en mer noire les pays bas
environ deux avions de combat à la
bulgarie l'estonie la lituanie et la
lettonie déplace des missiles antichars
et antiaériens en ukraine la france
quant à elle est prête à envoyer des
troupes en roumanie de leur côté les
autorités américaines confirment que
8500 soldats sont en état d' alerte
ce n'est pas parce que nous sommes prêt
et engagé dans le processus et la voie
de la diplomatie et du dialogue que nous
ne préparons pas à la défense et à la
dissuasion nous faisons les deux en même
temps précisément parce que nous sommes
prêts à faire face aux choix de vladimir
poutine quel qu'il soit la russie elle a
condamné ce renforcement militaire
qu'elle juge responsable de l' escalade
dans la région aucune sortie de crise en
vue pour le moment même si les
discussions se poursuivent emmanuel
macron doit notamment s'entretenir avec
vladimir poutine dans les prochains
jours
j'ai interrompu vous avez écrit un
article sur dans lequel parce que vous
rentrez un taux juste d'ukraine dans
lequel vous expliquer tous les scénarios
possibles d'une guerre russe en ukraine
et vous dit ça serait plutôt par l'est
ou par le sud qu'on pourrait envisager
une attaque russe militaire en ukraine
oui effectivement parce que c'est là où
il ya le plus
déployé alors bien sûr on parle de plus
de cent mille hommes du côté russe un
donc à avoir un petit peu la différence
avec les chiffres qu'on vient de voir
qu'ils sont quelques milliers d'hommes
placés dans des états de l'otan de
manière défensive donc on n'est pas du
tout dans la même situation
déséquilibrée en faveur de la russie
bien sûr très très grandement et puis
l'autre point c'est que la russie
encadrent complètement l'ukraine au nord
parce qu'elle déploie des troupes en
biélorussie donc à l'est et au sud dans
la crimée occupés et puis même à l'ouest
puisqu'elle la russie a aussi des
troupes dans une petite bande de terre
qui appartient la moldavie qui s'appelle
la transnistrie donc en fait l'ukraine
est complètement encadré et c'est pour
ça que l'otan place des troupes dans les
états de l'otan qui a autour papier de
problème si la russie envahissent mais
il a encerclé le président zelensky
l'ukrainien donc lui il évoque une
invasion plutôt de kharkiv la deuxième
ville ukrainienne à 30 km de la
frontière russe ça serait plausible
wilkie et au nord-est de la russie
effectivement oui c'est tout à fait
plausible c'est pas très loin de la
frontière - les contacts que j'ai eus
m'ont dit que c'était une ville quand
même importante avec beaucoup de
populations et que les citoyens
ukrainiens ont pas du tout l'intention
de se laisser occupé par une puissance
extérieure donc ça veut dire qu'ils
riposteraient enfin kiwi très clairement
il ya une grande organisation alors il
ya l'armée bien sûr mais aussi une garde
nationale en ukraine qui a été entraîné
au cas où eux-mêmes sur l'arrière pour
garder le territoire et puis aussi c'est
nouveau une bataillon de défense
territoriale ce sont des citoyens
ukrainiens qui s'engage dans une guerre
de guérilla entraînées par l'armée
structuré par l'armée mais en cas
d'occupation car servant c'est vrai
qu'on sent là les positions quand même
de chacun on est vraiment dans une
situation qu'on al'impression être très
dangereuses et poutine entretient un
flou il évoque aussi une réponse
militaro technique des frappes aériennes
ciblées ciblées j'avais aussi des
instances des installations de missiles
nucléaires en crimée il ya aussi
rajouter des cyberattaques ça a déjà
commencé puisqu'il ya déjà eu des à des
cyberattaques contre l'ukraine est ce
qu'il fait exprès de matières ce flou
oui effectivement parce que ce flou fait
peur entretient la confusion pour
rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit le
rapport de force entre la russie et
l'ukraine c'est le rapport de force
entre
un mammouth sibérien et puis une petite
souris avant totalement sa poids
disproportionné rappelle quand même que
la russie est une puissance nucléaire
une armée importante qui se bat en syrie
de façon d'ailleurs comment dirais-je
très très dur enfin s'en sent beaucoup
de respect pour les droits de l'homme
alors pour essayer de répondre à votre
question qu'est ce qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer déjà qu est-ce qu on
peut éliminer dans ce paysage c'est
quand même très tendu je crois que une
invasion massive
territoriale des forces russes pour
aller par exemple sur kiev c'est
vraiment une volonté de destruction
d'ukraine et d'occupation on peut le
lire vous pouvez écarter les salaires
prendrait quoi quelque chose
ça serait pas très très difficile mais
le problème c'est qu'elle est le but de
guerre la russie va pas après se battre
contre les guérillas contre toute une
population vote année un territoire il
faut tenir et or donc je crois c'est pas
du tout ça l'objectif l'objectif de de
poutine c'est vraiment de continuer à
casser la dynamique d'indépendance de
l'ukraine qui ne rentrera pas dans
l'otan certainement ni ni aujourd'hui ni
peut-être même dans 10 ans donc c'est
pas du tout sujet la préoccupation de
poutine c'est que son étranger proche
est en train de lui échapper et qu'une
certaine dynamique de démocratie de
différents pays on l'a vu en biélorussie
aussi avec les manifestations qui
sortent tous à lui échappe alors un mot
sur le plan militaire qu'à la savourer
qu'est ce qu'il pourrait faire d'abord
des cyber attaques je l'avais dit avant
qu'elle se déclenche non pas parce que
je suis de 20 mais parce que les russes
fonctionne toujours comme cela vous
aurez une intensification avec des cyber
attaques militaires ceux des objectifs
ni thèse qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui c'est pour l'instant des
institutions civiles après il peut y
avoir des opérations de forces spéciales
est quelque chose qui préoccupe poutine
ce sont les drones armés données vins
vendus par les turcs à l'ukraine et ses
drones peuvent changer un peu la donne
la donne dans le dombass dont vous
pourriez avoir des frappes ou des
opérations de forces spéciales russes
sur ce type d'objectif comme sur les
missiles anti chars qui ont été données
par l'administration autre homme et puis
autre langue après osé d'état de
variantes sur le plan territorial le
seul objectif à mon sens limité qui
pourrait rentrer dans ce que byron
maladroitement avait évoqué en disant
petite incursion petit répercute bonds
est une stupidité c'est une pénétration
sur le pourtour de la mer d'azov je
pense que l'un des objectifs de poutine
c'est de privatiser complètement la mer
d'azov qui est presque complètement
encerclée il ya encore une bande qui
appartient à l'ukraine là il pourrait y
avoir un objectif il a déjà fermé la mer
d'azov sur le détroit de kertch donc là
territorialement parlant c'est quelque
chose qui serait jouable et encore une
fois l'objectif c'est véritablement de
comment dirais-je de peser sur le cren
d'empêcher complètement ce pays d'avoir
sa liberté stratégique sans pour autant
se lancer dans une guerre de conquête
qui pourrait se retourner contre lui or
il a des problématiques nationaliste
interne intérieur il ne peut pas perdre
on peut pas rentrer dans une guerre où
la guérilla ne ferait pas un blitzkrieg
par exemple à la non alors il pourrait
le faire le big three que c'est ici il
déploie deux cent cinquante mille hommes
c'est dans cette ville par exemple
ukrainienne dont on parlait dont il est
effectivement sur le front biélorusse on
n'a pas trop parlé de sébastopol mais il
ya possibilité d'action / odessa par la
mer noire donc si vous voulez faire une
plus strict si voulez ça peut aller très
vite après il faut tenir dans le temps
et c'est pas un objectif militaire qui
l'intéressent et ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent et poutine il a les poches
plutôt plate plutôt plate kiev est pas
très loin de la frontière biélorusse 1
c'est une centaine de kilomètres ils
sont tout à fait capable de l'atteindre
mais de l'apprendre et de la tenir ça
c'est probable soit une autre paire de
manches les russes ont effectivement
démontré en syrie qu'ils avaient éviter
l'erreur américaine en irak c'est à dire
de déployer des troupes considérable
pour tenir le territoire les russes se
sont empressés de ne pas faire ça en
syrie il est probable qu'ils aient
retenu la leçon et qu'il ne fasse pas en
aucune façon ni graines d'anis mcshane
londres a rappelé une partie du
personnel de son ambassade à kiev
le royaume uni a livré des missiles
antichars à kiev quelques centaines de
soldats supplémentaires qui sont prêts à
être déployés en ukraine boris johnson
montre un activisme sur le front
ukrainien à ce qu'il veut montrer un
retour de la global britten sur la scène
internationale
un peu oui l'opinion publique bien sûr
nous avons subi les et actes poutine sur
notre sol il a envoyé des agents
des gpu pour tuer ces dissidences et aux
ponots en france a bien sûr vous êtes
bien pris par les états qu'ils la mise
pour nous c'est plutôt les et actes de
poutine et bien sûr l'angleterre ce sont
toujours pour isoler a appris le point
excite et c'est cette manière de dire
oui nous sommes présents le madame le
ministre faisait trop cher par pour kiev
demain ou après demain donc l'angleterre
à présent autant que bolo ton est aussi
aux tons que mon père beugnot les
conseil de sécurité de l'onu est-ce
qu'il veut pousser son avantage auprès
des états unis boris johnson il ya
toujours ce lien quand même entre le
royaume uni et les etats unis
non je crois que tu au bail domaine son
propre politique il envoie tony blinken
un long botté n'est pas un don le cru
petit nom m'ont dit qu'ils étaient
érigés la france l'allemagne les
etats-unis la russie a pour trouver
solution la première invasion est là
lajus de la chose de crime et donc
cccb messi jones --le a réduit la laf le
forces armées nous avons maintenant armé
brutalité à peu près 60 mille soldats
c'est beaucoup moins les prisonniers de
nos
prisons et il ya des vrais plainte
auprès des militaires qu'ils occupent le
haut à grasse tic de
gouvernement conservateur qui fit deux
eaux a affaibli en a la force militaire
wikileaks est une façon de dire le sont
toujours nous sommes toujours présents
et gueu borg grèce les autorités
américaines ont confirmé 8500 de leurs
soldats qui sont en état d' alerte on
voit que l'allemagne hésite entre berlin
j'ai lu empêché l'estonie par exemple
pays membres de l'otan d'apporter un
soutien militaire à kiev l'allemagne
hésite pour l'instant elle ne renvoie
pas troupes en ukraine est-ce que c'est
très important aujourd'hui pour
l'allemagne de ne pas vraiment participé
je crois que l'allemagne devrait
s'engager bien plus ça devrait aider le
cren et aussi permettre à d'autres
d'aider l'ukraine la banio ne vend pas
des armes et en plus en pêche que les
armes allemandes soient prêtés par nos
amis en europe a le crâne c'est à dire
ce que fait l'allemagne cède c'est
encore pire parce qu'un gouvernement qui
très pacifiste ce qui est très bien
quand je n'ai pas d'ennemi vive et quand
je ne suis pas en guerre mais maintenant
le crâne est en guerre c'est une
situation de guerre le prix du gaz en
allemagne à un triplé comme 65 % des
ménages sont chauffés par cass alors
tout ça s'annonce mal et je souhaiterais
que le gouvernement soit pu faire mais
c'est clair que nous avons un
gouvernement nouveau gouvernement
extrêmement inexpérimentés au niveau
international
mais un chancelier refuse de prendre la
direction de diriger en plus il a il a
une coalition il a des membres dans son
groupe oui qui sont vraiment des
pacifistes et là vous pouvez pas prendre
l'allemagne peut pas en ce moment là
prendre les décisions nécessaires
c'est le nôtre à 10 ans c'est vrai mais
ça vous le regrettez en tant que
représentant donc des conservateurs
allemands qui ne sont pas dans cette
coalition je le dis pour le
téléspectateur
j'espère que que la série ou qui étaient
à partir demain qui était toujours
contre les ventes d'armes dans ce cas là
je vois comment l'ukraine est sacrifiée
par l'europe et par les pays européens
dits on z pas il faut les aider sinon
c'est clair que l'alarmé ukrainien est
extrêmement mal équipés elle ne pourra
pas tenir je suis pas du tout de cet
avis elle pourra pas tenir et une guerre
de guérilla vous pouvez pas mener une
guerre de guérilla contre l'armée rouge
c'est quand même c'est quand même une
grosse blague vraiment à côté de la
russie ça c'est une autre situation
n'est pas en afghanistan c'est pour ça
que à mon avis maintenant soir on défend
la paix en donnant
des moyens de se défendre sinon ça aura
de graves conséquences
j'aime la vie
julien theron je vais j'allais faire
intervenir justement julien theron y ait
des divisions au sein de l'europe un jeu
absolument intéressant d'avoir d'écouter
une gloire grâce le qui a évidemment un
discours différent de celui qu'on peut
entendre aujourd'hui au sein de la
coalition allemande qui est
effectivement un peu de mal parce
qu'elle ne veut pas envoyer de troupes
tout en essayant d'être unie unis à la
france devrait il ya de vrais division
il ya de vrais division effectivement
alors ce qu'il faut bien comprendre dans
la question des ventes d'armes et la
question se pose aussi pour les
etats-unis c'est que il qu'on vend des
armes on demande aux pays acp qui en
levant de demander l'autorisation si
c'était pour leur envoyer ailleurs en
fait c'était le cas des états unis qui
ont finalement après beaucoup de
demandes autoriser les baltes à en
envoyer en ukraine ce que vous avez
indiqué dans votre infographie et
l'allemagne s'y refuse donc elle dit aux
baltes non le matériel allemand vous
n'avez pas droit l'envoyer en ukraine
donc très clairement c'est je veux
priver l'ukraine d'armement et ils ont
répandu on va vous envoyer un hôpital de
campagne c'est à dire un hôpital
pourquoi également sont ils si réticents
il ya un délire visuel ci fils mme comme
dit malgré cela au sein même du
gouvernement allemand notamment entre le
ministère
des affaires étrangères et la
chancellerie ça n'est pas les mêmes
lignes effectivement c'est un
gouvernement qui est assez jeune et il
ya une réticence réticences de
participer l'allemagne aujourd'hui et
celle qui freine le plus la france n'est
pas loin derrière elle prend des
engagements mais vous avez vu sur
l'infographie qu'on est prêt à envoyer
des soldats s'est pas exactement la même
chose que d'envoyer juste pour
précisions les rares soldats que le
royaume uni ou les états unis envoient
en ukraine sont des soldats pour former
aux armements 1 c'est pas des soldats
qui vont être envoyés sur le front
ukrainien et sinon tous les autres
soldats sont bien dans les pays
riverains de l'otan je vous fait réagir
pierre servant mais avant on va écouter
justement emmanuel macron et olaf scholz
c'était il ya un peu moins d'une heure
ils se sont vus le président français et
le chancelier allemand est justement ils
ont évoqué l cette question ukrainienne
on les écoute il y a le dialogue dans le
cadre du format normandie sur la
question on craignait des bureaux des
accords de minsk et il ya le dialogue
entre l'union européenne et la russie
chacun de ces canaux doit être doit être
exploité jusqu'au bout pour réengager la
russie dans un processus de désescalade
obtenir des garanties
il est le gouvernement fédéral a
toujours décidé ces dernières années de
ne pas livrer des armes létales
il ya des raisons qui s'explique
facilement au vu de ce qui s'est passé
dans l'histoire
une en même temps nous avons fait
beaucoup pour favoriser le développement
économique de l'ukraine
avec les moyens qui sont les nôtres car
servant donc il le justifie en disant
quelle histoire donc c'est le poids de
l'histoire d'une relation effectivement
entre l'allemagne et la russie
particulière bah oui oui ça se passe le
dans la nuit du 21 au 22 juin 1941 vous
avez
presque deux millions d'allemands de la
wehrmacht qui partent de envahissent la
partie polonaise occupée par les russes
ce qu'il faut rappeler quand même que
les russes était alliée de l'allemagne
nazie peu après donc traverse l'ukraine
où ils sont accueillis avec des fleurs
d'aider le sel dire que les ukrainiens
accueille les allemandes à wehrmacht
comme des libérateurs par rapport aux
soviétiques faut faut se souvenir de ça
ce qu'ils disent menus craintes et nos
pays frères certes vraiment la russe
historique du 9ème siècle elle est faite
à kiev mais vous entrez dans l'histoire
contemporaine y dix ans sur nos côtes
quant à nos amis allemands ils sont ils
sont légitimement traumatisé par le
troisième reich et ils ont une énorme
difficulté à imaginer la guerre et des
choses enfin des combats et des
opérations c'est quelque chose qui est
très loin ça a été très bien dit c'est
une condition qui est fragile par
rapport à ça donc ça va pas avancer
toute petite précision il faut quand
même dire les choses si parra si par
malheur poutine vraiment s'engage assez
massivement ce que je ne crois pas je
crois qu'il s'engagera je crois qu'il ya
des opérations militaires russes mais il
n'y aura pas de soldats de l'otan en
ukraine n'y aura pas de soldats de
l'otan pour défendre du cred en ukraine
donc ça soldats de l'otan sont
positionnés dans les pays baltes en épi
oui parce que les entailles pays si vous
voulez les pays baltes la pologne qui
ont connu l'hégémonie soviétique et dans
l'histoire l'hégémonie russe ils
tremblent de peur et il faut le
comprendre mais s'ils seront fortes
suffisamment justement armée ce que
design malgré cela c'est que finalement
ça sera déséquilibrée annoncé quoi
dessinant les ukrainiens vous avez dans
un discours de discours des propos
dignes de deux eric zemmour
que nous avons interviewé ya pas très
longtemps à c dans l'air zemmour dit oui
vous comprenez la russie est menacée et
encerclé un payant dit un pays de 17
millions de kilomètres carrés et organes
et 1,7 et il ya des missiles c'est comme
cuba ya des missiles qui le menacent
vous avez aucun missile se menaçant en
ukraine vous avez des missiles anti char
qui porte à 1000 mètres et va y avoir
des stingers c'est à dire des missiles
anti aériens à courte portée les
véritables missiles qui sont menaçants
ils sont notamment à kaliningrad
missiles 'iskander' qui portent des
têtes nucléaires et conventionnels et si
vous voulez qu'ils sont une menace
directe sur les pays baltes sur la
pologne et sur l'ukraine donc la
malheureuse ukraine s'il ya vraiment une
offensive majeure il faudra qu'elle se
débrouille avec les armements qu'on lui
donnera mais c'est une armée qui reste
convalescente qui en 2014 était tout à
fait une très très grande faiblesse
quand elle à la crim est a été conquise
qui a remonté un peu en puissance mais
qui ne fera pas le poids face à un
déferlement de militaires encore une
fois je ne crois pas au déferlement
poutinien mais il y aura certainement
des opérations militaires des russes en
tout cas emmanuel macron a l'air de
croire tout de même une certaine d
escalader prix il veut privilégier le
dialogue de nice mcshane est-ce que
lorsque vous entendez ça de la part
emmanuel macron vous pensez qu'il est
naïf ou pas
loge dit bonne chance le président bédié
n'a parlé avec monsieur poutine est ici
monsieur macro arrive à le persuader de
se retirer de ce cas lui serait très
bonne bonne chose mais c'est difficile
parce que comment si poutine va sauver
sa face parce qu'il pose des baux
possible reste resterez presse l' empire
soviétique terminé l'idée de l'auto tue
près de hockey khl et les polonais les
romains les ukrainiens perdent le droit
de
autodétermination civ à l'airé en ligne
européen pas question pour précieux
poutine le vrai menace vraie menace
c'est l'arrivée des nues créer une plus
démocratique - désolé car qu eux
et un droit jeunes lisent libre et
surtout orientations nouvelles aux
européens c'est là qu'il déteste parce
qu'il ne veut pas que le ver est enlevée
russie l'union européen arrive dans la
rue si c'était bien maintenant l
approche soixante dix on la pas par des
mesures qui nous veulent actuellement
dans le monde mais il est absolument
terrifiée que la russie va peut-être
échappé à son contrôle
donc si tu le mélange des choses je
penses tu pas moins d'états d'âme ainsi
monsieur macron vont se rencontrer à
monsieur poutine mais fais gaffe on va
lancer nouveau film ici en angleterre
grands récits qui s'appelle munich
assesseurs chairman de l'allier et 30
oui voilà peut-être la parole alan
emmanuel macron verlaine
wahba et on peut le voir sur les
numériques se bat edel des labos mais
c'était pas très flatteur ça se resserre
pas ingeborg grèce vous êtes d'accord
avec ce que vient de dire justement de
nice mcshane il ya peu de chances est ce
que pour vous et belle macro et naïf à
vouloir justement encourager le dialogue
et puis une autre question sur le gaz
russe est ce que l'allemagne serait
prête à renoncer à ce gaz russe pour
sanctionner la russie
c'est une des blogs en développement
tout récent que le gouvernement ait dit
voilà on peut renoncer à notre film 2 de
le mettre en oeuvre
si la russie attaque l'ukraine mais il
faut aussi on est dans l'état de droit
là il faut aussi une base légale voilà
ça c'est tout nouveau on verra bien ce
que ça donne qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous pas ce que c'était le projet
d'angela merkel nord stream à me
semble-t-il c'était aussi la cd ou était
favorable aux leurs oui pour le moment
les socialistes était le premier
lobbyiste de ceux
de ce truc là d'une ancienne de toujours
les socialistes
et bien sûr bien sûr c'était un projet
important privé économique bien sûr que
nous on avait toujours eu l'allemagne a
toujours eu une bonne relation avec la
russie nous voulons de bonnes relations
avec la russie mais nous voulons aussi
sauvegarder la paix en europe est ce que
fait la russie c'est la guerre en
ukraine et c'est la guerre en europe et
dont vous auriez près ajusté à renoncer
à nord stream à ce gazoduc j'ai appris
donc des années c'est ce que le
gouvernement a dit que l'ue de
nordstream s'il ya cette attaque là
alors là si je peux plus me fier à ça
alors là je ne sais pas où j'en suis
c'est là que est clair qu'ils peuvent
pas faire ça mais à mon avis monsieur
monsieur macron il n'est pas naïf c'est
clair que c'est le dialogue c'est
toujours clair que c'est le dialogue
pour l'europe mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
nous si c'est déjà clair que le dialogue
ne suffit pas alors là il faut pas être
nostalgique il faut pas être naïf non
plus à mon avis il faut prendre des
mesures supplémentaires au fait que le
crâne puis s'auto défendre il y va de
son auto défense il va pas que que
l'otan ait des aides est un soutien
ukrainien
à combattre non mais cette auto défense
soutient c'est une demande légitime et
là il faut vraiment que l'europe bouge
il faut aussi que les allemands bush qui
commence à réaliser qu'on ne peut pas
prêcher la paix et qu'on peut que que la
prière désolé ne suffit pas on ne se dit
pas julien theron l'allemagne pour
effectivement renoncé au gazoduc north
stream 2 donc ce projet qui après des
années dont qui en fait tu vas pouvoir
va permettre d'exporter du gaz russe
directement en allemagne on sait que
c'était très tendu avec les états unis
sur cette question parce que les états
unis souhaitent l'utiliser comme
sanction est ce qu effectivement
l'allemagne y est jusque là et bien ce
soir on a appris que les états unis
réfléchissent à des solutions pour
comment dire
renforcer l'approvisionnement en europe
dans le cas où parce que ça n'est pas
que van gaal et oui ça n'est pas le cas
uniquement de l'approvisionnement en
général c'est le cas de six la russie
voulait prendre l'ukraine par exemple ou
n'importe quel autre situation de
tension il pourrait dire à l'allemagne
directement et bien maintenant nous vous
coupe le gaz et d'ailleurs ça aura des
conséquences considérables sur l'ukraine
qui a une part de son pib de droits de
transit du gaz donc là c'est l'inversé
c'est ça que donc c'est en gros c'est
donner plus d'outils à la russie pour
faire pression et alors ce dialogue là
il est pertinent bien sûr mais il ya
deux choses dans le dialogue j'avais
discuté avec michael mcfaul qui était le
conseil de barack obama et le le
l'architecte de ce qu'on appelle la
politique de without terre la remise à
niveau toujours de nos politiques avec
le kremlin et qui est plutôt pas
fonctionné il est qui avait plutôt pas
fonctionné la livre passant des flandres
je vais pas bon mais ce qu'ils disaient
c'est que ce qui ce qui est très
important dans une politique de dialogue
et là dessus d'ailleurs nos amis
britanniques le disent extrêmement bien
notamment l'année ce qui agace c'est
qu'il faut d'une part savoir exactement
ce qu'on veut atteindre dans ce dialogue
est ce qu'on veut qu'il se retire de de
crimée est ce qu'on veut qu'il se retire
du dombass par exemple est ce qu on veut
qu'ils retirent leurs troupes d'autres
de l'ukraine et puis deuxièmement il
faut avoir les moyens de son dialogue
c'est à dire juste dialoguer pour
dialoguer sans faire pression ça ne
marche pas on est face à une planque la
pression ce sont les versions possibles
les sanctions possibles il peut y avoir
il ya deux grandes branches de la
stratégie en général via l'économie et
le militaire donc il faut que ce sont
des militaires on l'a vu sur l'économie
justement il ya ce nord stream 2
justement est-ce que effectivement
pierre savant il pourrait décider les
allemands de ne pas utiliser ce gazoduc
dont se faire livrer ou l' inverse la
russie pourrait couper du gaz il ya
évidemment une pression autour du gaz et
puis il ya d'autres sanctions que j'ai
vu que les états unis s'apprêtent à
adopter c'est la sortir la russie du
système swift c'est à dire des
transactions financières ce qui ferait
très mal à la russie est autre chose
également ils ne veulent plus exporter
de technologie à la russie donc la cua
ont touché là où ça fait mal et qui
meurent là tout du côté des européens
des américains tout le monde travaille
pour regarder qu'est ce qui pourrait
être fait c'est là aussi du côté de
poutine
qui est une sorte de jeu déchets de
joueur d'échecs mais avec une mentalité
de joueurs de poker menteur qui va
regarder comment jouer sa partie je suis
persuadé qu'il veut aller une opération
militaire tout ce qui a été dit
notamment par notre ami britannique est
infiniment juste il est il vieillit il
dans en 2024 quand il aura terminé son
mandat ça fera un quart de siècle il est
au pouvoir il voit que son espace autour
de lui lui échappe il donc la craie mais
ça ne suffit pas non non c'est vraiment
une question je pense de fond c'est une
question idéologique très très fort en
même temps il va regarder comment faire
pour essayer de passer en dessous du
maximum détention pourquoi parce que on
parle de la pénalisation de l'europe et
des allemands si le gaz est coupé mais
la russie est extrêmement dépendante de
ses clients c'est à dire que si elle ne
vend plus de gaz elle aussi va se
trouver étranglée et rappelez vous que
le pib de la russie ce pays gigantesque
richissime c'est l'équivalent du pib de
l'espagne où des pays-bas absolument
donc c'est un pays qui est en grande
difficulté et c'est un problème de
poutine vous l'avez rappelé tout à
l'heure sur sa campagne en syrie que
j'ai étudié très très près ç'a toujours
été une des campagnes à l'économie
d'abord pas troupes au sol pour pas
risquer la guérilla mais le moins cher
le moins cher possible avec le maximum
d'impact donc poutine ira jusqu'au bout
il doit aussi offrir à son opinion
publique intérieure après les jeux
olympiques tout ce qui va se passer son
bac avec à ses fins parce qu'il va pas
content fait pas guéri il appartenait
son pays d'aider médailles que ces
champions vont rapporter des jeux
olympiques de pékin donc si vous voulez
les bruits de bottes sérieux pourrait
commencer fin de février d'abord les
manoeuvres avec la biélorussie seront
terminées le 20 février donc la fenêtre
de tir très préoccupante c'est fin
février début mars et d'ici là les
partis diplomatique il en a rien à faire
et on ne négocie pas en diplomatie si on
a quelque chose à la négociation en ce
moment dans toutes ses négociations avec
mes fils aujourd'hui
il faut le faire mais elles ne servent à
rien pourquoi parce que dès le départ si
on nous avons négocié tous les deux
quelque chose quand j'arrive en disant
voilà mes propositions et un peu faire
ce que charles pasqua ministre de
l'intérieur faisait jadis ce qui est à
moi est à moi ce qui est à vous est
négociable donc ces versets la position
poutine vous n'avez pas de négociation
diplomatique pour ce cas là pour
renforcer ce qui vient d'être dit
effectivement les négociations originel
les demandes originales c'est un retour
aux
membres de l'alliance atlantique avant
97 c'est à dire qu'il faudrait que les
trois pays baltes les polonais les
bulgares les macédoniens les
monténégrins la roumanie se retire de
laure et l'otan ça c'est ce qu'a demandé
vannière poutine départ mais gêné bien
et les américains ont été très clair il
parle pas pour toute l'organisation mais
sur 2 allait demander aux estoniens de
se retirer de l'otan vous allez voir
l'inacceptable il m'a alors évidemment
si vous mettez la barre beaucoup trop
les analystes russes eux-mêmes de
plusieurs think tank à moscou on dit il
est évident que il n'y a aucune volonté
de concéder quoi que ce soit et ils
l'ont dit ils ont lire on négociera on
ne retire à aucune de nos demandes donc
dès le début si vous voulez très
clairement il ya une demande qui est
très poussée et une course tout donc on
est dans un chacun montre ses muscles
par une construction que poutine bâti
depuis six sept mois avec notamment le
fait qu'il a dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'un génocide se préparer dans le
donbass et c'est pas autour de lui c'est
dit j'ai retrouvé ça dans des papiers de
conseillers proches de poutine un
génocide se prépare dans le don basque
qu'est ce que ça veut dire vous avez des
fausses négociations diplomatiques
vous avez cette affirmation là il y aura
certainement dans les semaines qui
viennent dans le donbass un incident
grave une école qui va brûler une
maternité qui sera attaqué et poutine
pourra mettre cela sur le compte du
début du génocide et à ce moment là il
pourra dire nous rentrons dans une
partie de l'ukraine n'ont pas pour
l'envahir mais pour défendre les
russophones qui sont menacés de génocide
c'est ça la construction psychologique a
été faite par poutine deathmatch n vous
êtes d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit est ce qu'une solution diplomatique
est possible
j'espère que oui je ne sais pas le vrai
problème n'est ce pas c'est que l'euro
lui ni le européen autres chefs europe a
refusé de prendre sérieusement la
question de la défonce 1 il ya deux ans
messieurs maquereau a dit que le taux
était mort cérébrale mme si c'est très
gentil maintenant en effet à ce désastre
pour monsieur poutine les suédois et la
finlande pas série seconde laissé
derrière eux la nu tarrit et et entre
temps le ton le problème c'est que le
politique étrangère le aux petits plutôt
végétarienne mais saumade merkel
politique étrangère de l'alba n'était
vega fait strictement rien et
aujourd'hui un dire que c'est quelque
chose avec l'arrivée des gouvernements
société veut pas dire aucun changement
de la politique en albanie et marc
marquez à celles pratiquées trop j'ai
été là commerce le commerce le commerce
est le pays qui frottent les mains à
tous nos difficultés c'est la chine la
chine et là nous avons fait rien à
résoudre le problème de beaucoup
occidentale monsieur macro se laver les
mains de ces problèmes est partout en
europe on n'a aucun leadership digne du
nom est ce que monsieur poutine va
envahir je le perds ce bourg mais c'est
si désastreuse pour son prix vous croyez
que fajr le gard servant
que poutine oreilles c'est l'article
caille rien
il n'aurait donc pas vernis les
terminaux en effet les yeux il fait les
unes des journaux it pas cela talib
télévision turnball discute la russie le
retour de la russie c'est bla bla bla
bla bla bien en effet un beau c'est ça
un vrai un gain kinetic envoyé les chars
et blindés les avions et ça va provoquer
des réponses très très sérieux et là on
aide aux réseaux des désastreuses
la russie devient la syrie
de l'europe et je crois que a
il faut si on peut le trouver petite
porte la sortie wii offre
loin mais pas question de dire vous
contrôlez ukraine l'ukraine n'a pas son
droit à l'autodétermination mais aussi
je vous en prie pour le président saleh
de ce qui fait quelque chose que ce mec
vous oligarques fait quelque chose pour
toi liberté de presse a eu de crédit m
oui dans de meilleures options
diplomatiques de ces d'après ce que vous
dites qu'une petit petit peu ingeborg
regret cela vous êtes d'accord avec ce
qu'il vient de dire 10 matchs sk une
petite marge de manoeuvre par exemple
effectivement les occidentaux l'amérique
pourrait dire on va retarder l'entrée de
l'ukraine au sein de l'otan en mettant
une conditionnalité par exemple
effectivement à faire en sorte qu'il y
ait moins de corruption dans ce pays est
ce qu'il ya une sorte de matière à
discuter qui permettent justement qu'on
parvienne à un accord
mais qui a dit que le grain va rentrer
dans va rentrer dans l'otan s'étaient
jamais question franchement cet homme
cet été un pur prétexte c'était clair
que le statut de neutralité de l'ukraine
personne n'y touche ça c'est vrai que
c'était toujours la ligne de madame
merkel est d'ailleurs du reste d'autant
aussi s'était jamais question alors là
c'est clair que ni la rentrée de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne s'était
jamais question franchement il y avait
un accord de coopération qui a été
beaucoup changé c'est clair que le
statut et mes plans de le crème pour
l'avenir ont changé mais je me rappelle
plus qu'il a dit c'est clair que le
peuple ukrainien à des projets aussi et
le peuple ukrainien veut se diriger vers
l'ouest et vers les valeurs de l'ouest
et c'est clair que c'est là peut-être la
menace pour poutine mais je me demande
tout le temps bien sûr ça va ça va aller
se massent ces masses de trous sur les
frontières voilà c'est peut-être un
scénario de guerre qui a déjà qu est à
la guerre qui est très avancé là parce
que vous dites à julien theron un petit
mot justement est ce qu'il ya une petite
marge de manoeuvre tout de même pour que
la diplomatie
puisse vaincre
cette négociation autour du statut du
week-end alors ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre et moi ce qu'on m'a dit à
kiev c'est qu'il faut arrêter de
concerts l ukraine comme une petite
russie où une ancienne russie où quelque
chose qui appartiendra la russie ou sur
lequel la russie à droite de se
prononcer ils m'ont dit on est un état
souverain on a des élections
démocratiques
on n'a pas demandé l'autorisation à nos
voisins pour prendre nos décisions vous
voyez donc ça c'est quand même un point
important en revanche du point de vue de
moscou le discours est complètement
différent c'est à dire que
l'asie oui il n'y aucune différence
entre les russes et les ukrainiens l'âme
quelques conseils si on pourrait
accepter les états unis justement pour
qu'on puisse avancer
c'est vraiment là où on est vraiment
dans un appart cul de sac une impasse
exactement pourquoi parce que il y
aurait matière à des négociations
diplomatiques assez large sur une
architecture de sécurité de leurs
voudrait emmanuel macron
manifestèrent blinken a proposé il ya
plein de sujets parce qu'il ya eu des
blocages avec trump il faut rediscuter
sur les armes de portée intermédiaire le
open sky donc la démesure de réassurance
qui permet de surveiller les choses les
manoeuvres le fait de près en fait il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut mettre sur
la table et qu'on peut discuter
légitimant avec les russes et les russes
peuvent avoir des demandes légitimes
mais c'est pas du tout ça c'est je crois
que c'est jean yves le drian caddie les
russes nous nous voulons continuer
l'esprit d'helsinki les russes vol delta
je crois que les russes veulent bien
tard ce serait quoi il yal'etat de
poutine ou alors les sudètes peutrec
l'intro de suite retrait de l'otan des
pays de l'est mais un mécène il
n'obtiendra jamais non c'est ce qui
manque c'est pour l'instant le client
fait si vous voulez il ya des
possibilités selon qu'il faut arriver à
vous dire qu'il y aura partage non mais
c'est pour ça que c'est pas poussé parce
que le galetas isolé ça consiste à
accepter que poutine et ce regard sur
l'étranger proche il appelle l'étranger
proche qu'il consolide c'est à dire que
en biélorussie il a tordu le bras le
cache une coquille a besoin des forces
russes la situation est effectivement
tendue parce que les ukrainiens qui sont
accusés l'otan qui est accusée dans
d'encercler la la la la la la russie
vous l'avez dit c'est eux qui sont
complètement encerclé et encore plus
qu'auparavant puisque par la biélorussie
vous avez des avions
des systèmes de défense sol air et puis
vous avez la marine russe et c'est donc
le pouls poutine le kazakhstan poutine
est intervenu aussi à la demande du
président cazeau tindall conflit en fait
à vous écouter il se sert du compte
saisir du conflit nous illuminer son
d'étrangers progrès et le conflit nous
paralyse complètement et on est en
permanence en train de faire des pas en
arrière parce que ça nous fait peur de
rentrer en confrontation en disant à
chaque fois mais vous n'imaginez pas une
guerre avec la russie mais ce qu'on ne
comprend pas c'est que le kremlin lui
même ne veut pas la guerre avec l'otan
il n'a pas les moyens financiers ni
militaire d'une guerre avec l'otan donc
c'est pas comme ça que se passe la
guerre aujourd'hui c'est en place des
pions et les autres n'y vont pas
exactement comme en syrie avec les
oxydes on est encore dans la phase de
test chacun c'est une espèce de
tectonique et là où on ne comprend pas
c'est nous on se dit il vaut mieux qu'on
se retirent rapidement et qu'on fasse
des solutions négociées évidemment comme
l'y mettre la barre très très haut à
chaque fois en recul mais c'est est
dangereuse c'est avec le cyber c'est le
décès laisser les scellés coup de
trompette le cyber les attaques de au
cyber écoute trompette beaucoup à pierre
haas avant d'avoir été avec nous vers si
je viens theron merci à vous ingeborg
grèce là d'avoir été avec nous en direct
de berlin et merci à vous donner ce
match et d'avoir été en direct de
londres avec nous merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis et reste avec nous sur
france 24